(epic pewds)
How dirty...
is your mind?
*static noise*
97%
impossible, no!
not enough
I said not enough
100% impossible
*"damn son where'd you find this?" meme with ear rape*
1% impossi-
dammit
*more static ear rape*
million percent impossible
how dirty is your mind?
can you pass, this test?
this is brilliant just make a stupid fucking face
and add a picture to the left
lets let me- let me do that
*camera snap*
got'em
and add circles
circles and arrows!
more circles
more titties!
you know, if i uploaded a video like this
it would fucking get- flagged so fast
cause you guys are fuckin' assholes
so we're gonna keep it nice and clean
anyway, lets begin the test
f- you folks at home can play along
okay, alright
so far
I don't see anything wrong
it's just 2 girls
hangin' out
OOOOOOOOHHHHHH MY GOD!
she's fingering!
oh wait no..
it's her leg.
*pewds thinking about life*
there's nothing wrong with 2 girls fingering
that's disgusting
*laughs*
*hahaha*
prayers, they change things
they change hallelujah!
*more laughing*
woah
they're just cuddling
okay, they're just cuddling [sure]
Squirting shower spray
yeah, tha-that is hw-how how I shower
just like it
like it all to rain down on my face
that's-
*laughs*
what the fuck
hey, anal beads
How is that a dog?
That's a hairy dick
That ain't no dog
I actually don't see it at this one..
*silence*
Is it pe-
What the fuck is it with legs?
I don't understand
They freak me the fuck out
ok
alright
this is
this is bullshit
We need to step it up a bit
30 pictures
that prove you have a dirty mind
I don't have a dirty mind!
That's a girl's asshole
Honestly, I don't know what else it could-
It's her elbow!
WHAT?
*laughs*
Why do they look so similar?
Why did God make elbows and ass cracks so similar?
Coincidence?
Ah-
I think not!
Someone.. has a weird fetish!!
moving on..
Oh my God!
I can't look at this!
I can't look at-
Marzia!!
This is disgusting!
I wouldn-
I refuse
I am blocking it with the microphone
I do not see it
I swear
[...]
Now that's
either some weird ass looking titties
or..
*laughs*
I love her face
I don't know what I'm looking at!
Is it-
Is it like this?
Like elbow?
Is it elbows?
The elbows don't really mo-
It's elbows..
It's elbows
*dramatic jumpscare sound*
OH-
Oh it's a corridor..
it's
It's just a corridor
uh
Marzia
please
I was just looking at a co-
A nice
corridor
I think the real challenge here
should be if you could jerk off
to any one of theese
*laughs*
You can mindfuck yourself
enough and be like
yeah!
Yeah this is some good shit!
OH MY GOOOD!!!
It's her aaaarm
-my god
what a fuck?
You know, if I
If I ever get the chance
to take a photo like this
I would
Right before I click
I would be like
*blows a kiss*
Thank You Lord
for making arms
look so fucking weird
Then I would never share it to anyone
I would just keep it to myself and the-
you know..
*derp*
Hey, Felix
whatever happened to that picture?
These ladies are really comfortable
with their friends
They're man-spreading
And that's disgusting!
They're woman-spreading
Oh, I see, it's ok
when girls do it
disgusting
What is this?
Are they gonna make a Netflix show out of that?
A really intimate massage place
Jesus Christ
Noo
Nah-
What the fuck?
What's wrong with the world?
Mama
People living like that's an-
vagina
I've always wanted someone to vagi-
va-
ahh..
I didn't think they would be this fucking
horrific
NO!
Pastor! Please!
What is that?
What is that??
wa-
I don't wanna go too close
What is that thing??
That's his dick
What else could it be?
Either a-
Either a snake
Is that a sna-
I don-
Comment down below
if you know what it is
cause I don't know what-
*laughs*
the
fuck
Nothing like a good ol' family picture
Where the daughter is..
sh's uhh..
She either has very disproportioned arms
or
her hand is down her dad's pants
*laughs*
She's punching her pussay..?
I don-
I am so confused
I didn't think it wold it would be this pervert
You know, I'm pretty perverted,
And I'll admit it
I'm not afraid o-
uuh
Oh you have a dirty miind!
Yeah
I do
I think we all do
moving on
I don't see it
I see it
i see it..
What the fuck is that thing? (wtf pewds)
That can't be fake
what is that?
It's the
Oh my God!
it's the bike-
*laughs*
it took me so long
This reminds me um-
when Lady Gaga
had the rumor of her having a penis
Do you remember that?
I remember when i saw that
the first time and I'm like
That's a dick.
That's clearly a dick
THERE IT IS THAT'S A PENIS!!!
Why is her tit showing, Shelby?
Oh, never mind, it's your arm
God damn Shelby
always showing your titties
Shelby!
Why is your tit showing?
Can you tuck it back in
at list for the god damn facebook picture
Ok, I don't see-
oh my God
nevermind
Where do these penises come from?
I ha-
I'm startin' to develop a theory
in my mind
about ghost penises
I'm writing it right now
The theory is that girls
have penises
that will only appear
during certain
Facebook pictures
I have about 500 more pages to go
but that's the intro
It's another ghost penis!
ghost peniiis!! (*singing*)
This one- I don't get
I- Uh-
I've seen this one a million times
It's
an ass crack
I don't see the problem
*laughs*
Ehh
I am seeing a vagina right now
I don't know what you're seeing
I am seeing a vagina
Ghost peniiiis!!!
Strikes again!
OH MY GOD
IT'S A FRU-
IT'S A TOMATOOO!!!
It's the vagina-
What the fuck is that?-
Oh it's the-
*laughs*
Every picture's like
wha- e- fgfffgfngf
OH!!
This is slut shamy, ok
there's nothing wrong with two woman-
touching each other
This one
I remember first time I saw this one
I was like
Why would you do that to that baby?
*laughs*
Fuck this picture
it took me fucking ages
You gotta look pretty bad
if your fucking shoulder
looks like your fucking head
and combined look like an asshole
Can you imagine being that baby
growing up?
Oh m-
What?
What is-
It's an elbow!! (no, pewds, that's an armpit..)
Fucking elbows (*armpit )
Why do they look so weird??
It's not an elbow
what's-
arm- arm wrest [???] arm.. crack [???]
whhat-
*laughs*
Yeah I'm just tired now..
like just fucking giggling like-
hehe- he- it looks like a penis
*laughs*
See, it happened again..
Brothers fucking
*laughs*
well..
cath- you know-
Catholic priests
what can I say?
*laughs*
You know when people find like Jesus..
in toast?
And stuff like that
If I were to find Jesus in a toast
I wouldn't care
However
If I find a penis in a- in a clementine
that's when I know
God is real!
*laughs*
Wha-
who- who-
who would put their dog up somewhere?
you pet it
and you make this fucking face?
*laughs*
Like it doesn't exist-
Edgar-
*laughs*
poor Edgar I'm sor-
[gaah so cutee^^]
JESUS!!!
OH IT'S A PIG!!!
You didn't say that that was a pig-
what the fuck you dirty minded son of a bitch-
C'mon!
Tell me honestly did you th-
*laughs*
Did you pass the dirty mind test?
Only..a 1000% can't make it
Share this video-
ehe-
if you failed
on your Facebook
Be sure
to like
share
and also
post this
on-
your email
listen, I'm just tryna-
broaden my audience a bit
it seems like we're running a little too high
And check out another video
right here
If you have a dirty mind
leave a comment down below
ah-
aahh
aaaahhhhh
I love it